à compreignac petit village de l'aveyron
de 250 âmes le maire est sollicitée tous
les jours par les équipes des candidats
à la présidentielle en vue d'obtenir sa
précieuse signature avec la fin de
l'anonymat des parrainages mise en place
en 2016 l'édile sans étiquette refuse de
faire ce choix seul et d'engager ainsi
la responsabilité de ses administrés et
femmes et les hommes de compreignac en
elle une liste apolitique donc avec tout
le panel de parrainage on sort on se
retrouve pas et on
je ne choisirai pas pour les habitants
de la commune par par respect pour la
démocratie
de mes concitoyens donc je ne donnerai
pas mon parrainage à cette élection
présidentielle pour respecter le choix
des villageois il a voulu mettre en
place une consultation citoyenne pour
désigner le candidat par aînés mais
voilà le préfet de l'aveyron pas tout à
fait de cet avis a décidé de lui
adresser un rappel à la loi une attitude
dénoncée par le maire de compreignac je
ne peux faire une consultation citoyenne
que sur les choses qui concerne ma
commune est donc là apparemment donc les
présidentielles ça concerne forcément la
france même si moi je parle plutôt du
principe que ça concerne ma commune de
choisir à qui nous donnons le parrainage
mais bon apparemment c'est illégal
l'interdiction d'organiser cette
consultation populaire et pour olivier
julien un déni de démocratie
les habitants de la commune très investi
dans la vie locale regrette de ne pas
avoir pu s'exprimer sur ce sujet moi je
trouve ça vraiment dommage venin à sous
préfecture on aurait quand même aimé
avoir la vie des villageois mais bon une
consultation populaire je pense que ça
partait d'une bonne intention et c'est
plutôt une bonne idée pour avoir un
petit peu la vie de tout le monde
maintenant si si c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas forcément autorisé ma foi tant
pis à moins de trois semaines de la date
limite pour obtenir les parrainages
aucun candidat ne pourra compter sur le
soutien du maire de compreignac la
course continue donc pour convaincre les
autres élus à ce jour quatre candidats
et potentiel candidat à la
présidentielle ont obtenu les 500
signatures